des personnalités ont accepté de vivre
une retraite spirituelle coupée du monde
pendant une semaine et tout cela en
silence
elles partageront le quotidien strict
d'une communauté religieuse dans un
monastère historique frère budouin
rejoint par sœur Catherine pour
l'expérience consacre leur vie à la
simplicité l'humilité la pauvreté juste
mon père si je peux me permettre vous
avez pas le permis c'est ça vous avez
pardon mais lorsque l'on est une
personnalité publique ses règles
ancestrales sont-elles simples à
suivre et je dis pas un mot de la
journée mais évidemment vous ne dites
pas un mot de la journée oui mais j'aime
bien négocier je voudrais vous inviter à
vraiment rentrer dans le silence parce
qu'on vous entend parce qu'on vous
voit repas pris dans le silence
recueillement prière célébration
procession